we know that climate change triggers
extremes of weather
over 150 million americans are currently
under
winter storm warnings or experiencing
freezing weather conditions even in the
traditionally
warmer southern states snowstorms have
covered texas which is in the grip of
its coldest winter in decades
in oklahoma there's up to eight inches
of snow
on the ground and in tennessee it's
plunged to minus
11 degrees celsius scientists say this
cold weather is because of what's called
a polar vortex
but what does that mean and is it linked
to climate change
to understand what's happening in the
southern united states we have to look
north to the arctic and the polar vortex
it's an immense whirlpool of cold air
circling over the north pole
and when it gets disrupted this can
cause havoc with weather patterns
like we're seeing in the usa at the
moment a weakened polar vortex
can also disrupt the jet stream the
fast-moving winds that drive our weather
pushing freezing air south events like
this
are not uncommon and can happen once or
twice a decade
but arctic temperatures reaching as far
as texas
will sound alarm bells for scientists
there is some
evidence that global warming is making
the jet stream
slow and weaken more often which allows
cold air to travel
further if this is the case climate
change means we could increasingly
experience
a taste of the arctic further south than
previously imagined